collision theory can be related to
maxwell-boltzmann distributions and
first we'll start with collision theory
collision theory says that particles
must collide in the proper orientation
and with enough kinetic energy to
overcome the activation energy barrier
so let's look at the reaction where a
reacts with b and c to form a b
plus c
on an energy profile we have the
reactants over here in the left
so a
atom a is colored red
and we have molecule bc over here so
these two particles must collide for the
reaction to occur
and they must collide with enough energy
to overcome the activation energy
barrier so the activation energy on an
energy profile is the difference in
energy between between the peak here
which is the transition state and the
energy of the reactants so this this
energy here is our activation energy the
minimum amount of energy necessary for
the reaction to occur
so if these particles collide with
enough energy we can just get over this
this activation energy barrier and the
reactants can turn into our two products
if our reactant particles don't hit each
other with enough energy they simply
bounce off of each other and our
reaction never occurs we never overcome
this activation energy barrier as an
analogy let's think about hitting a golf
ball so let's imagine we have a hill and
on the right side of the hill somewhere
is the hole down here and the left side
of the hill is our golf ball
so we know we have to hit this golf ball
with enough force to give it enough
kinetic energy for it to reach the top
of the hill and to roll over the hill
and go into the hole so we can imagine
we can imagine this hill as being a hill
of potential energy
and this golf ball needs to have enough
kinetic energy to
to turn into enough potential energy to
go over the hill
if we don't hit our golf ball hard
enough it might not have enough energy
to go over the hill so if we hit it
softly it might just roll halfway up the
hill and roll back down again kinetic
energy is equal to one half m v squared
so v
so m would be the mass of the golf ball
and v would be the velocity so we have
to hit it with enough force so it has
enough as a high enough velocity to have
a high enough kinetic energy to get over
the hill
let's apply collision theory to a
maxwell boltzmann distribution usually a
maxwell boltzmann distribution has
fraction of particles or relative
numbers of particles on the y-axis and
particle speed on the x-axis and a
maxwell-boltzmann distribution shows us
the range of speeds available
to the particles in a sample of gas so
let's say we have here's a particulate
diagram over here let's say we have a
sample of gas at a particular
temperature t these particles aren't
traveling at the same speed there's a
range of speeds available to them so one
particle might be traveling but might be
traveling really slowly so we'll draw a
very short arrow here a few more might
be traveling a little faster so we'll
draw the arrow longer to indicate a
faster speed and maybe one particle is
traveling the fastest so we'll give this
particle the longest arrow
we can think about the area under the
curve for maxwell boltzmann distribution
as representing all of the particles in
our sample
so we had this one particle here moving
very slowly and so if we look at our
curve and we think about the area under
the curve that's at a low particle speed
right this this area is smaller than
other parts of the curve so that's
represented here by only this one
particle moving very slowly
if we think about this next part of the
curve right most this is a large amount
of area in here and these particles are
traveling at a higher speed so maybe
maybe these three
particles here would represent uh the
particles moving at a higher speed and
then finally we had this one particle
here right that we drew this arrow
longer than the others so this particle
is traveling faster than the other one
so maybe
maybe this area under the curve up here
is represented by that one particle
we know from collision theory that
particles have to have enough kinetic
energy to overcome the activation energy
for a reaction to occur
so we can draw a line representing the
activation energy on a maxwell boltzmann
distribution so if i draw this line this
dotted line right here
this represents this represents my
activation energy
and
instead of particle speed you could
think about the x-axis as being kinetic
energy if you want so the higher the
faster a particle is is traveling right
the higher its kinetic energy
and so the area of the curve the the
area under the curve to the right of
this dashed line this represents all of
the particles that have enough that have
enough kinetic energy for this reaction
to occur
next let's think about what happens to
the particles in our sample when we
increase the temperature so when we
increase the temperature the maxwell
boltzmann distribution changes so what
happens is the peak height drops
and our maxwell boltzmann distribution
curve gets broader so it looks something
like this at a higher temperature
so we still have some particles
traveling at relatively low speeds right
remember it's the area under the curve
so maybe that's represented by this one
particle here
and next let's think about the area to
the left of this dashed line for ea so
let's make these particles green here so
we have some particles traveling at a
little bit of faster speed so let me go
ahead and draw these arrows a little bit
longer but notice what happens to the
right of this dashed line we think about
the area under the curve
for for the for the magenta curve notice
how the area is bigger than in the
previous example so maybe this time we
have these two particles here traveling
at a faster speed so i'm going to draw
these these arrows longer to indicate
they're traveling at a faster speed and
since they're to the right of this
dashed line here both of these particles
have enough kinetic energy to overcome
the activation energy for our reaction
so we can see when you increase the
temperature you increase the number of
particles that have enough kinetic
energy to overcome the activation energy
it's important to point out that since
the number of particles hasn't changed
right all we've done is increase the
temperature here
the area under the curve remains the
same so the area under the curve for the
for the curve in yellow is the same as
the area under the curve for the one
drawn in magenta the difference of
course is the one in magenta is at a
higher temperature and therefore there
are more particles with enough energy to
overcome the activation energy so
increasing the temperature
increases the rate of reaction